for Oklahoma young driving the fluttery
got first to portray on that's what he
does no not a lot of just wow you type
moments but they basically run team when
he throws it down on the feet from young
this early but when you watch with Trey
young has done it's fun to talk about it
because he is just exciting to watch
another assist
Freeman the stretch poor for New Zealand
crunch on the corner
does it go for Smith young in transition
walk wait for help inning rolls in
[Applause]
Shivani McNees suma came for the first
time
shakes loose underneath he's got four
points pants is the classic event
substitute and nobody knew who they had
[Applause]
only what he's gonna do
let alone the defense
- Steph Curry being 60% from the field
in this ball game young taking no
kristance and it'll go to the line after
the close tech closed house he's soft -
tears - saw it for I think he need to
admit that playing well now and
[Applause]
fists for young to Odom's see on the hem
young 18 points 9 assists and there's
truck so that is 12 straight games for
Oklahoma State well that's what managed
to get the weight room so I feel the
battle inside to get Salomon two more
for you